let's take a closer look at the decrepit
struggling barely functioning guy in the
white house
who sees apparently jim crow around
every turn
remember joe biden he once called
african-americans predators
on our streets he worried that his
precious children
would grow up in integrated schools that
he
referred to as quote racial jungles his
words
he bragged that his home state of
delaware was quote
my state's a slave state he said he
worked hand in hand with america's
most notorious racist to block the
integration of our schools and bussing
robert byrd the former clan leader was
biden's mentor in the senate according
to joe
and the rest of the democratic party
none of that matters
and now according to joe millions of
americans are worse than jim crow
all because they support simple
election integrity measures watch for
yourself
21st century jim crow assault is real
it's unrelenting there's an unfolding
assault
taking place in america today an attempt
to suppress and subvert
the right to vote and fair and free
elections
the assault on free and fair elections
is just such a threat
literally i've said it before
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
since the civil war joe probably
remembers the good old days i guess in
his life
he served what delaware how many years
at this point let's break this down for
you
according to joe biden america is facing
its worst crisis since the civil war
because of the texas election bill look
at your screen tonight
this bill bans paid ballot harvesting
you have a problem with that
it requires voter id for mail-in ballots
alternatively voters can provide the
last four digits of their social
security number if they prefer
the bill sets uniform times for early
voting all while expanding early voting
hours on the weekend it ensures that
poll watchers
are able according to law observe vote
counting
start to finish all sides get to observe
it strengthens the ban on
unmanned mail in drop boxes so nothing
nefarious can happen keep people honest
it gives voters an opportunity to
correct mistakes on mail-in ballots if
they're discovered
the bill requires those assisting voters
with filling out their ballots to
complete a form
verifying their identity and it ends the
temporary emergency measures
that were put in place because of the
pandemic like drive-through voting
and 24-hour early voting joe biden quite
literally is calling this bill the most
racist thing to happen
in the united states this century all
right pretty insane especially
when you consider this simple fact
because of this bill
it is now easier to vote in texas than
in joe
biden's home state of delaware that's
why he's now weaponizing his own
department of justice to go after
atlanta
they have far more accessibility to
voting than delaware
and in the state of texas there are two
weeks of early voting in delaware
there are zero weeks of early voting in
texas there are drop locations for about
absentee ballot
ballots in delaware well drop boxes
well they're not required both states
require
voter id but in his what five 000 plus
years representing the great state of
delaware
joe not one time ever voiced any concern
whatsoever
about his own state's restrictive
election laws never
not once instead he was too busy saying
things like
well this
madam president we have predators on our
streets
the largest growth in population is
indian americans
moving from india you cannot go to a
7-eleven or a dunkin donuts unless you
have a slight indian accent
what kind of a chance would a
northeastern liberal like joe biden
stand
in the south better than anybody else
and you don't know my state my state
was a slave state you got the first
sort of mainstream freaking american
who was articulate and bright and
clean and a nice looking guy i mean this
that's a story
you're gonna put you all back in chains
we got more questions
you got more questions but i tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black the guy that
tried to slow
integration of our schools eulogized the
former
clan leader called obama the first
uh articulate and bright and clean
african-american this is storybook man
those are joe's words now that guy joe
biden
uh is he's going to lecture the country
about racism
really now allow me to state a fact that
might surprise joe biden
americans regardless of their race or
gender
they're capable intelligent human beings
i have faith in the american people we
don't always win the elections
we want to win but you know what we come
back conservatism
always makes its way back because it
works now way before covert
before all of the mass mail and ballots
and the 24-hour drive through voting
centers
and the weeks and weeks of early voting
african-american
turnout was actually reaching record
levels
now in fact it was a study according to
the associated press even
printed in the washington post that
african-american voters turned out at a
higher rate than white voters
in 2012 and in 2008 but texas democrats
they don't appear interested in facts
grandstanding is far too important to
them and so democratic lawmakers they
fled their state
in order to prevent a quorum and thereby
temporarily blocking a vote on this
legislation
earlier this week they boarded their
private jet no masks in sight just a
sidebar and are now enjoying a lavish
vacation in washington d.c
complete with speeches and selfies and
partying and tweets
about what they're eating kamala harris
called the trip
courageous in line with the brave
actions of frederick douglass watch
i had an extensive meeting yesterday
with
i think some of the most courageous
elected leaders
that we could know at this moment
i said it yesterday and i'll say it
again they took
bold courageous action
in line with the legacy of everyone from
frederick douglass was over my right
shoulder
when he fought for the right of black
men to vote in america
to the legacy that includes all those
women who marched down pennsylvania
avenue
for women's rights to vote to all of
those folks who shed their blood on the
edmund pettus bridge
to make sure that we would in 1965 pass
the voting rights act
now [ __ ] mcconnell republican
colleagues skip town to prevent a quorum
in the u.s
senate let's see how kamala harris
reacts then
would they call them courageous will she
be calling republicans courageous i tend
to doubt it
so what is this really all about we all
know there is nothing racist about
integrity in elections democrats are
obviously worried
chances are they are now believed they
probably will lose in 2022
and maybe even 2024. their green new
deal
socialist policies are deeply unpopular
they're defunding the police dismantling
police reimagining police policies
are similarly deeply unpopular the guy
that they put in the white house is
becoming less and less coherent
seemingly by the hour so now they are
frantically searching for ways to expand
voting by any means necessary
all while setting up an excuse for an
impending loss
mark my words if democrats suffer huge
losses in 2022
they will blame racist right-wing
voter suppression mark these words down
per usual
it's all a lie but the truth isn't
important to the democratic party or the
media mob for that matter
power is all that matters hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else